in today's video we will be ranking
levi's top 10 fights in attack on titan
let's get started number 10 levi's
appearance
only a few episodes in we got to see
levi for the first time at that time he
was just a badass guy who had a talent
for killing titans at that time we
didn't know just how much we would grow
to love him the scene where we first got
to know levi was his very first fight
only a perfect fight could have
introduced him and in my opinion his
introductory fight definitely did him
justice i mean suddenly he went from the
rude guy we didn't notice to the guy we
wanted to know all about in this fight
levi appeared out of nowhere to save
aaron and let's be honest that happens a
lot in the anime doesn't it anyway aaron
gets defeated by two titans and is about
to get eaten when out of nowhere the one
and only captain levi shows up and gives
the titans a fight that they were
definitely not ready for it was a
jaw-dropping fight not only for us but
for aaron mikasa and armin as well
number nine levi meets irwin
[Music]
levi is the strongest soldier in the
survey corpse we all know that but how
did he end up there if you've watched
the bonus episodes about his past i'm
sure you know that but if you didn't go
watch them right now because his
backstory is definitely worth knowing
these bonus episodes also include one of
his best scenes the moment when he met
irwin smith i don't know about you but
since the start i always wondered why
levi respects and admires irwin so much
if you know levi you'll know he's the
kind of guy who does what he wants but
in front of irwin he never says no well
that's because when they first met irwin
actually saved levi's life levi and two
of his friends used to be criminals
living in the underground and in this
scene the survey corps including irwin
finally catch him however instead of
killing them or sending them to prison
irwin convinces levi to join them just
like all of us irwin was totally
impressed with levi's skills as well
irwin really didn't give him much of a
chance though but regardless we're all
thankful to irwin for making levi end up
with the survey corpse
number eight levi vs kenny round two
throughout the season levi was so
desperate to kill kenny and we were
cheering to see him dead so in this
scene he finally managed to get it done
levi's squad went into the caves to save
aaron and they had to fight kenny's
squad to do it the overall fight was
amazing but to add to it we saw a 1v1
between levi and kenny even though kenny
managed to trick levi at the start
obviously at the end of the day no fight
is too hard for levi he catches kenny by
surprise and severely injures him kenny
manages to escape but he later dies due
to his injuries number seven levi's big
decision you know what has to happen
airvin gets the shot
yeah most of levi's finest moments are
his fights but let's mention one moment
that isn't since this scene is probably
one of my favorite levi moments it was
when erwin and armin were both dying it
was so emotional and suspenseful that we
just couldn't keep our eyes off the
screen levi had the titan serum and he
had the option to save only one of them
obviously he wanted to save erwin but he
realized that that would only bring him
back to this cruel world and just like
all of us levi had tears in his eyes but
he decided to save armin did he make the
right decision it's up to you to decide
number six
levi vs beast titan round two
deep in the forest of giant trees zeke
manages to trick levi and escape his
imprisonment this led to yet another
thrilling fight between them which left
the beast titan defeated falling towards
zeke levi fires and hits zeke's nape
with four thunderspears before quickly
detonating them cutting zeke's mangled
and burned body from his titan form i
mean this time from the looks of it it
seemed like levi finally managed to kill
zeke obviously that wasn't the case but
this fight was still one of the finest
ones fought by captain levi
number 5 levi vs female titan
one of the first titan shifters we got
to see in the anime is the female titan
the first time it showed up we were all
confused and very scared it killed many
of levi's closest friends including his
personal squad it was a very sad moment
and to make it even sadder it ate aaron
as well thankfully he was in her mouth
and she didn't swallow him like many
other scenes levi comes in out of
nowhere to save aaron i mean it could be
a great drinking game just taking a shot
every time and ackerman swooped in to
save aaron although the female titan
attempts to fight back it begins to get
overwhelmed by the barrage of attacks
inflicted by levi allowing him to
incapacitate her while gaining the
chance to slice her titanform's mouth
and rescue aaron from within
number 4 entrance to liberio
yes getting to know more about marley
and its heroes in season 4 was great but
let's be honest it was like a breath of
fresh air when we finally got to see the
og characters and like many other scenes
this one was to save aaron as well shot
time and seeing levi after so long was
just incredible his entrance to liberia
was actually one of his finest moments
after the jaw titan sneaks behind and
jumps on aaron's back levi takes note
and goes to intercept it the jaw titan
tries to bite into the neck of the
attack titan but levi severs the muscles
in the left side of its face rendering
it unable to rip out the nape terrified
porco could just stand still and watch
as other soldiers started engaging him
as well
number 3 levi rage mode
among all levi's fights we don't really
get to see levi's emotions a lot he's
not an open person and he seems to keep
his emotions hidden he's always calm and
he calculates his every move but at this
moment he just couldn't levi was
separated from friends when they were
outside the walls without him furlon and
isabel died by getting eaten by a titan
levi went in complete rage mode slicing
the titan that killed them in over 100
pieces even though it was a sad scene it
was also one of his most stunning fights
number 2 levi vs kenny
this is basically the fight between
humanity's strongest soldier and the guy
who actually taught him all his skills
it was the first time kenny showed up
and we were all confused about who he
really was and to add to the confusion
levi was so pissed to see him it didn't
make any sense well obviously we later
found out the whole backstory and found
out kenny is his long-lost uncle who
actually taught levi everything he knows
about fighting and survival levi shoots
kenny by aiming with the bottle's
reflection and this shot hits the chair
kenny is holding but is still strong
enough to throw him back outside and
levi takes the opportunity to escape
this was probably one of the very few
fights where levi actually got injured
but even so he ends up with a win
number one levi vs beast titan
the top of our list is not just levi's
best scene but probably the most iconic
scene in the entire attack on titan
series the first fight between levi and
zeke i'm sure you all remember the first
time beast titan showed up we were all
scared of what kind of monster this was
i mean he threw rocks and killed so many
of our favorite characters whenever we
saw him it gave us goosebumps and we
just prayed no other character we loved
died and the worst part was it seemed
like no one could ever defeat this
monster but at the end of the day
nothing was impossible for captain levi
even the monstrous beast titan seemed to
be nothing in front of him this is one
of those fights that literally gives you
chills down your spine i mean the way
levi brought down a gigantic ape with
little to no effort man it was perfect i
don't know about you but this is one
attack on titan scene that i can never
get tired of and with that we come to
the end of this video i hope you enjoyed
the video and if you did make sure to
give it a big thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel and we'll see you guys next
time